you're dating a loser if he lacks depth
has no other interest than watch
football drink beer play video games
obviously this is generalization this is
stereotyping Etc it's just a metaphor in
this case this could be translated in
all kinds of different shape sizes and
forms in reality all I'm saying that
it's about a man who lacks depth cuz you
know there's this stereotype that women
or often times women can be AirHeads
especially blonde women so you know they
say that a woman can easily be an
airhead a d bimo a blondie you know all
of those horrible stereotypes but come
on have you never heard about the fact
that a man can equally be so and the
fact that actually in this world there
are so many of them oh yes